sometimes I walk around with a naked
case free iphone then sometimes
something like this happens yeah walking
around with a bear or naked phone just
doesn't make sense especially if you've
got the iPhone 6 which is especially
slippery and is a protruding camera lens
that can easily scratch yes a clunky
plastic case probably is going to
destroy your iPhone beautiful design but
here's the case I'm gonna make in the
next few minutes a case can actually
make up for the iPhone shortcomings
Apple phone is better with a cover hey
lady
did you know having a case on your phone
doesn't mean that it won't break yeah I
hear this from anti case people all the
time and it's true but it depends on how
bad the fall was and what kind of case
you have for instance if you have a
crappy case like this one that doesn't
even protect the sides then yeah you're
pretty much screwed a good case will
protect the edges or the corners which
are the first parts to usually hit the
ground and crack the most important
thing to look for is a little lip that
rises above the screen since the screen
is usually the first thing to break you
want the case to come into contact with
the ground before the glass I've tested
a number of cases that meet that
criteria but if it looks like Tupperware
I'm not going to recommend it my pick is
the $20 Incipio NGP it barely looks like
you have a case tech 21 $35 classic
frame has even more protection for the
edges though it is a bit thicker Apple's
own cases are also a good option
especially the leather ones there's one
place I'm willing to deal with the
thickness of a case though and that's if
it doubles my iPhones battery life the
good news is that battery cases have
been slimmed down but pack even bigger
batteries of the five I tested the $80
incipio off grid Express was the best
not only was it thinner than most but it
gave me a full charge and then
water happens and iPhones have never
liked it but there's good news
waterproof cases no longer look like
submarine tanks like the lifeproof fre
power not only can it endure a drop in
the toilet but it can charge your
battery right inside there and if you
don't need a battery inside go with the
light curve mood it's waterproof without
even having a cover on its screen the
iPhone is slowly killing the wallet but
Apple pay isn't accepted everywhere and
most of us still need a photo ID which
is why I've fallen in love with the
wallet case you want to look at the MU
Joe Wyatt case the leather is soft cards
easily slide into the back and it has
that protection on the sides like we
discussed earlier you see cases are far
more than just ugly pieces of plastic
yeah sure it would feel great to go
naked but you know what feels better not
worrying about this